haha my old friend dude my old friend
Joey Coco Diaz give a wrong applause
everybody everybody
Kasab do not Bobby Lee Judy's this but
it's a pleasure having you in my overall
much room how many time done yours a
couple of time round yeah yeah yeah you
always trying to get me on nine o'clock
perfect they've been asking me for you
but they're like you know you know I I
don't like asking people because I want
people to say no no [ __ ] ask for you
you said yes right aware with your
family I was I was very honored that
you'd even have me a criminal are yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I was in Canada
and and the club owner I Calgary was
like what should I bring here I go what
ads I go first foremost joy Diaz and he
goes can even get in the country and
then he I go oh yeah he has
criminalities criminal yeah you hit
somebody with a pipe what happened along
EEOC's hit somebody with a pipe
no I kidnap somebody oh this drug rip
you did a drug rep yeah like you show up
and you're supposed to have cash but you
have dick was in Denver where's that
collar right over yeah Boulder a Boulder
Colorado that's how I've heard of it
yeah
there's Cubans out there no I want our
takers they were looking for me in
Jersey yeah yeah you went out I was a
Hellion man yeah you were it's so funny
out and when I met you I was just
crossing over my doctor I was crossing
over like once I got to the Comedy Store
I was still a criminal I'll still throw
a glass at you yeah yeah that deef and
[ __ ] and all that scamming [ __ ] went
away cuz I saw other scammers up there
and I saw how bad it look it's a full
house of scammers that's not the houses
cameras what's cleaned out now but
before Deadwood how to go in there and
[ __ ] rock the house you had a rock
the house you had to [ __ ] always
check your back pocket always right you
know when I was up there addicted to
coke you know the first five ten years
yes not blow and [ __ ] I forget that
because I used to when I was using drugs
I used to give you pills all the time
yeah you remember that oh yeah please
maybe them I know you [ __ ] yeah you
wouldn't even ask me he would just look
at me
uh-huh and I'll just pull it out oh but
he was eating them yes yes I trust ya if
the FDA approves them [ __ ] it look good
don't give me that ching ching [ __ ] my
big card for today
I'm gonna give you you know it's so
crazy I've never been addicted to pain
medication like the big thing in this
country now that was the opiate problem
people give me a Viking the two
sometimes a couple weeks right to the
podcast and a dude I had a stash of
pills on a Sunday at like 12:00 like oh
just give me whatever just to get the
party start yeah I was [ __ ]
so like 10 [ __ ] hours on movie yeah
yeah but 10 hours I was roasted yeah the
pills like mid podcast by the time I got
my car was sizzle it was like 1 o'clock
in the afternoon he was opiates oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I was high till 10
jack like Sam I was like you okay yeah
hey there's no edible that was
straight-up [ __ ] opiate I'll tell you
what day I'm like that's fine
I got high I got no regrets I did it I
manned up to it Wow but I'll never do I
don't know how people do that you don't
get you never because you never got
physically addicted maybe maybe that
you're a mentally strong no I got I got
hooked on all that [ __ ] like I got
hooked I want two phases yeah
like when I first started comedy I was
selling these antics I was selling
volumes ah
and you know the bringer shows yeah
that's how I would bring people American
ingenuity so even though you call me
eleven o'clock strung out yeah nothing
till eight o'clock at the comedies right
and I made you pay what the [ __ ] Joey
the samox only cost me a quarter I would
sell them for a dollar fifty Wow so I
would just give you full on the house
man you made me come on
yeah I was making a move yeah me made
the comi store at eight meet me the
Comedy Store at eight me meet the Comedy
Store they make sure you know got eight
people why would you do it Imam American
ingenuity with immigrant mentality
lethal weapon no our what I wanna what
yeah I you know that's alright I saw
Shannon when I first got divorced I had
this [ __ ] up Mexican dude in Longmont
Colorado
I had a trailer and half the trailer was
pills and yeah everyone by the way as a
Mexican dude I had one Paul yeah oh my
god yeah once a week and he would give
me do you remember the old days crackers
coming at 10 saltine crackers yeah he
had me at 10 like every time I go over
there like we the Mexican food yeah yeah
give my envelope and he give me a 10 and
I take it home like it was crackers like
those cookies cookies yeah yeah yeah
meanwhile I had [ __ ] one hundred and
thousands an X Isabella Valley Wow
and then I sold that [ __ ] for a while
when I got off that I just went to New
York and so coke one thing I was a very
very good coke salesman I never took a
pinch for cocaine you can't [ __ ] get
me at all you couldn't get me yeah I
knew when they came as a matter of fact
a DEA agent came from my show on sad
then gave me a card and he goes I heard
you one time in a podcast he goes you
had all the procedures down I know
exactly when somebody comes and they're
looking for for [ __ ] so I never took a
pinch for [ __ ] drug sales or
possession know that [ __ ] my [ __ ] was
straight-up
robberies amazing you're not dead it is
is it not I almost died a few times I
almost died in Beaumont Texas can you
imagine that Beaumont Texas after The
Longest Yard
[Music]